welcome back after lunch so the next
speaker is pay one is going to tell us
about an optimal it ain't over until
it's overviewing so take it away
thank you uh good afternoon and okay so
uh let's see what is this hidden over
here it's over theorem and this is a
joint work with Jonah Alden and Harvey
Victor
okay
uh so okay uh sorry maybe you probably
already know this background but let's
still review it very quickly
and all starts this talk is about
Boolean function analysis so we first
review this notion of influences I think
in the morning Dan already set up for me
so here we have a Boolean function
and the influence of individual variable
is just the probability that you flip
this variable x i
so that you flip the value of a function
over uniformly random input
is just a maximum over all the
individual influences
okay uh and here are some examples the
first one is the majority function uh
this example actually matters for our
results so let's see the majority
function simply outputs uh the majority
bit of bits in books
and the max influence of the majority
function is one over square root then
the reason is simple because when a bit
to be sensitive meaning if you flip that
bit you flip the value of a function it
has to be the case that in your input
there are approximately equal number of
zero animals like in this case zero one
zero one zero you flip zero you flip the
majority bit
and also like you know the probability
over uniformly random inputs that you
have approximately equal number of zero
and ones is one over square root of M
and the conditioning on that event
any bit is sensitive with constant
probability therefore the max influence
of the majority function is 1 over
square root of n maybe any questions
about the definition okay good can the
second example is the so-called tribes
function uh you have this and composed
with or
and the depending is set so that it
outputs 0 and 1 with a bro with
approximately equal probability
particular the Fanning to the and gate
is n over login
and depending to the or function is
about log n minus log log n
so you can also uh
calculate the max influence of the types
function is log n Over N so this is
maybe an exercise for you
so in this talk we will be interested in
such functions namely the functions
whose Max influences is very small like
in the previous examples they are
polynomialism
and also we will say that for Simplicity
let's just say that these functions are
put 0 and 1 with about equal probability
of uniformly random inputs and we call
such function balanced function
so uh if if this is the first time that
you see these kind of functions uh it's
a little bit weird
but there are many motivations for
example they shows up naturally in
Social Choice Theory
so I guess uh maybe on Friday we have
the happy hour somebody prefers to go to
Oakland and somebody prefers to stay in
Berkeley
so you have to make a decision and
you aggregate your opinion and maybe use
the majority vote to decide where to go
and there are like more complicated
situations and you want to design more
complicated uh aggregation function like
when we elect the president maybe we
have this majority composed with
majority kind of function
this uh but uh uh in many situations
what we would want to uh what the
property that we would we would want to
have for this kind of aggregation
function is that no individual should be
able to determine the outcome regardless
of other people's opinion and this is
kind of captured by Max influence being
small
and the other the second motivation
comes from the study of hardest
approximation
so we know there is this dictatorship
test you want to distinguish a dictator
function meaning an individual bits
determine the output of your function or
functions far away from dictatorship
function that's functions whose Max
influence is small
and maybe a certain reason you these
kind of functions are interesting is
because of this invariance principle
a typical example is the central limit
theorem
so if you have if you want to take a sum
of independent minus one plus one random
variables
uh no none no variable that kind of
dominates the output therefore you can
actually replace this uh Boolean valued
function Boolean valued random variables
with a gaussian random variables and the
sum of gaussian random variables is
precaution
okay
so in this talk we were just studying
the random restrictions
um such functions so functions with
small individual influences
maybe for conquering us let's just say
uh uh in this talk we want to study the
random restriction such that you fix
exactly P times n number of random bits
and you can also think of random
restriction that uh fix uh input with
independent uh probability p
that's also fine
okay
so maybe uh any questions at this point
so so what we proved it's also there's a
so-called in then over here it's over
theorem is that
for any function
that its Max influence is more
then we can actually restrict
or but one over log one over the max
influence
fraction of the inputs
and what we have is we show that the
restricted function will remain on
constant with high probability if the
original function is balanced
okay so recall that for majority
function and traps function
uh the max influence is
so it's kind of saying that you can
restrict uh for those kind of function
you can restrict or but to one over log
and fraction of the inputs
and now this already tells you that this
theorem is uh optimal with respect to
this allowed probability because for the
tribes function it adapts to a Serial
circuits therefore using hashtags which
is Lemma if you set the probability to
be order of 1 over log n it's you are
going to get a constant function with
high probability
uh you can also calculate it in this
probability on your own
and another thing I want to mention is
that here I only say okay this restrict
function is non-constant but actually
you can also say how non-constant it is
so uh
you have this notion of variance and
it's kind of saying okay even after the
Restriction your restricted function
will be somewhat balanced
and this matches uh the behavior of the
majority function
so in this sense we give a tight
analysis on the behavior of the variance
okay
any question about uh
wait what is the youngest probability of
variance yeah uh
no oh okay yes yes I mean like um yes
yeah by the other direction I mean the
majority function behaves like the other
direction
okay so uh maybe more comments is this
uh very cool name it n over till it's
over is actually contributed by Fred
good and collide so in the study of
social Choice Theory we will see this
application later
they are interested in the case where
the allowed probability is a constant a
very small constant here we definitely
go beyond that
we can be a little over
and also the original conjecture was
proved already by mosul Donald and the
well let's give it
uh but they are the result is
sub-optimal
uh so this is nice
and also I heard that uh call Ellipsis
means there and most of they have a
different proof so uh maybe at some
point they were teachers
so okay maybe uh
before I move to Applications any
questions
okay
I hope that you don't ask
yes yes so
um
so like as I said for example if you
consider the tribes function you you
need to keep the two together constant
function you need to get like uh the
light probability to be order of uh one
over log n
and here what we get is like log log uh
and over log in so uh
so in between we don't know how to
analyze
so maybe now let's move to the
applications the first one is about
block sensitivity it's actually our
original motivation to study this
problem
so uh using this result we can show that
if your function is balanced and with
more influences then
the block sensitivity
on the random
input will be at this log 1 over the
maximum place
uh almost surely
okay so just maybe to remind you what's
sensitivity and block sensitivity
sensitivity is just that
well any input X it's just a number of
bits that you can flip to flip the value
function
and the block sensitivity is just
the number of disjoint blocks of
variables that you can flip to flip the
value of function so box sensitivity is
clearly larger than sensitivity
okay say it again
no yeah that's the next
next line
we don't expect such results for
sensitive just because of the majority
function
because the majority function for most
of the inputs their sensitivity is zero
foreign
and also another thing I want to comment
is that just using the KKR inequality
you know that the expected the average
sensitivity is at least log 1 over the
maximum Plus
therefore the average block sensitivity
is also at least log 1 over the maxing
places
and we are kind of saying that the
average is large because of what block
sensitivity is because every input has
large block sensitivity
okay
uh maybe let's see how this is proved so
we just uh uh take a random input
and you partition it into random blocks
of suitable number of blocks
and now for any fixed block
if you look at this input X and the
other
blocks
then that actually gives you a random
restriction
and by our theorem
this part
is non-constant this restrictive
function is non-constant with high
probability therefore within this block
you can flip
something to get a different value so
there so within this block there is a
sensitive block
and basically then you can show that
with high probability a lot of these
blocks uh contains a sensitive block
okay so that's the first application and
uh so here it kind of uses the fact that
our result uh about the live probability
is our people
and the next application maybe let's see
why we want to understand the variance
uh not just that the restrictive
function is not constant
so this application comes from the
social Troy Theory
so we know you know that we have like if
we have two candidates blue and red
and we want to maybe I prefer blue over
red so this is me
one just indicates that my preference is
blue greater than red
and now within this uh room maybe people
have different opinions so we just put
it in this array
and to aggregate our opinion we can
apply any function f
and we say that
if we say that we prefer maybe the blue
uh if this function give us one on this
array
okay so this is the case where we have
only two candidates
and not much to say
but uh it becomes more complicated when
we have more than two candidates
if when we have three candidates
um the question is how we aggregate
um
our opinion
and the the story is
uh I guess uh condorset was and uh their
friends I guess they were trying to come
up with a voting scheme to elect members
for French academic of science
so a quite serious uh situation
and the Qantas condo set just proposed
this method that okay let's just apply
maybe f
on different arrays
of these numbers and let's see how they
Aggregate and the hope is that we get
something
meaningful like here maybe uh uh as a
group we prefer a green than blue and
red and the blue is greater than red but
uh you can think about it it's not
necessarily uh the case that it always
come uh comes out this kind of rational
outcome you can get a circle
uh okay
so that's just to call this kind of
condo cell uh condo set profile as the
outcome
and we
um yeah we want to just say Okay so
let's say we have this function that's
fair in the sense that it's a balanced
function so
the two voters have equal chance to win
and also this say this this function has
more max influences
then let's make like a little bit more
assumptions otherwise we can't really
say anything the more assumptions we are
going to say okay the voters preferences
are uniformly at random uh overall the
rational
or over all the total ordering of these
candidates
and then we can prove that uh
any condo set profile will happen with
constant probability
so any irrational outcome can happen
with the constant probability
uh okay so for case uh
okay so so the the the approach we're
generalized is for K greater than three
and you are C
um
maybe any questions about the statement
of theorem
wouldn't say any conversation
no I mean the like uh I give you this
graph directly graph
like uh you can have you can put any
direction on these edges the condo set
profile is just impossible ways where
this would be eight options yeah okay
yes
okay
so if it's like a more KK for large K is
it still constant pump
um
so it seems that you always predict uh
what I'm going to say yeah so for large
okay I mean like um we can't do okay but
for some small case we can show for us
for our approach what we get is
exponential decay
uh uh and I don't expect this to be the
right answer
so this is open for you
okay
so maybe let's just see the proof
so uh
what we are going to do is we are going
to partition the voters into three
groups
it's random partition
so I belong to the first group of second
group or third group who is probably
one-third
um and then what I'm going to do is
for the first group I only ask them
what's their opinion
um red versus green green versus blue
can't afford a second group out only ask
them what's their opinion on blue versus
red red versus green and
Etc
and then uh
we should notice that
um
with this so far for me for example if I
give these two opinions
then
with a constant probability that I
cannot defer what is my opinion on blue
versus red
right
um
so uh and for the other thing maybe I
can differ maybe I can defer what given
for example I know reality is greater
than green green is greater than blue
then I know okay red is greater than
blue
so that is inferred that's fixed and for
the all entries that's not fixed
and all the entries that's fixed
it'll give us a random restriction
so now
the total probability of a live the
total probability of this restricted uh
probability you can calculate is a
constant and therefore we can apply our
theorem and show that
the restrict function
is now constant and in addition the
variance is very large with balanced
so now just notice that for these three
different kinds of
columns they are independent
so uh we can show okay for any possible
outcome with this constant probability
in ratio up
any questions
so if you are interested uh there are a
lot more you can find in particular most
of us in this survey
so now maybe uh let's return to our main
result and see uh what happened there
so maybe just recall what we proved so
we want to study random restrictions
with functions such that their Max
influences is small
and our strategy is to study some random
processes and relate that random process
with this problem
we are interested
okay so uh let's start with the simple
with the start with some setup and the
most simple random process the setup is
that we are going to think our input is
encoded by -11
this is because we want to go beyond the
building Cube or maybe go inside the
blink
so we will think that this function not
just evaluates for Boolean valued inputs
but also for any real value value inputs
by considering its multi-linear
extension
and now uh the uh the most the basic
random process we are going to study is
this uniform process
in particular we're just going to expose
the variables in a random order
and in the beginning
when we know nothing about these inputs
we just let them to be zero
and each time we expose a variable
so maybe uh in the first time we expose
this variable and in second time maybe
we expose another variable
so we were only using like zero one
minus one this is like the minimum
possible way to go inside the Boolean
Cube
okay
and also when we expose uh the variable
uh it's going to be set one or minus one
with equal probability
so is this process clear
any questions
okay
now maybe uh let's just make some simple
observations about this process so first
uh at time t
you expose T variables so it kind of
induces a random restriction with t
variables fixed
and at Time end you get uniformly random
element from your booty Cube
and another thing that's relevant to us
is the influence
of a function
uh it's just the partial derivative at
the end point
um
squared
I mean this is because the influence the
individual influence of the variable hex
I is the probability you flip your
function by flipping this variable
and partial derivative
with respect to this function had to
variable I is also
flipping this variable because it's a
multilinear function so flipping this
variable and see if it changes or not
okay
and maybe the the fourth observation is
that
consider this time T running from zero
one two
and evaluated at our function f then
what we get is a Martingale
this is also a simple fact from
multilinearity
of our function f
okay
what does f
XT is partial isn't complete yeah yeah I
mean okay so okay so when we when we not
restrict this
there
but we have negative one zero and one
yes and we can evaluate it because we
are going to treat it as a multilinear
all right function the zero is like a
random
[Music]
okay
so that's the most basic uh random
processes and actually we are going to
modify it a little bit
in particular when we expose the
variable now we don't set them to be
plus one minus one with equal
probability we are going to choose a
probability
such that in the end we actually sample
uniformly random element
that's uh from the pre-image of one for
this function f
and in fact in each step we choose one
or minus one based on like the
restricted we look at the restricted sub
Cube and see how much once is inside
them
and the probability distribution is set
to be proportional to the density of
each of the sub Cube
um
so maybe I want to mention one more
property of this process
is that suppose we fix any pass by pass
I mean like in the beginning we have no
information in the you know time one we
fix some variable time 2 we fix some
other variables
and ATM T So this entire pass
this is what I mean by pass so fix any
such pass the probability our second the
condition process follow this pass
if we compare it with the probability
that the uniform process follow this
path it's going to be F evaluated at the
endpoint divided by
F0 I mean intuitively it's just saying
our condition process has this bias
towards uh going to one
so when whenever the sub Cube has more
ones it has higher probability go to
that sub Cube and whenever desktop Cube
has less ones it has this condition
process has less probability to go
inside that sub Cube
that's all it's saying
okay sure definitely um
so our goal so our goal is
making sure that this process end up in
the uniformly random element
whose evaluation on air phase one
and in particular what we're going to do
is okay if we restrict if we are exposed
this variable if we set it to one we get
a restricted sub Cube and inside this
sub Cube there is many maybe this number
maybe this number of ones
and if we set this variable to be minus
one then within another sub Cube
then maybe we have a different number of
ones we just want to set the probability
to be proportional to the number of ones
in this sub Cube and the sub Cube
X
pictures
okay then sorry maybe it should yeah it
should be one
all right thank you
so I guess there maybe it's also uh here
it doesn't matter
[Music]
okay
maybe any any more questions
uh
just besides it's still a margin yet but
there's a step size no no it's not uh
why it's not uh
so now we will change our perspective
so we started this so-called Control
process that's going to be a bridge to
connect uh our theorem and the random
process we discussed so far
so in particular we are going to study
the following them
still we are going to expose the
variables in a random order
but now with probability with a large
probability we're going to expose the
variable uniformly at random
and with the remaining probability we
are going to let the player you to
decide
uh what to how to set the value for
these variables
and your goal is to sample
a pre-image of one
uniformly random for this function f
okay and uh here
I just want to say okay if
if you think about it
if in the end of this process
you don't have control then you
basically lose automatically
so uh we give more freedom to the player
we set some time
that's close enough to the end point
and we just say Okay after this time you
do whatever you want
and now we our goal is to show okay
after this modification
then as a player you can actually win
this game
so let's see how this is related to our
theorem first
this is just because if we look at this
uh points that's not controlled by you
it's exposed at random then that gives
you a random restriction
and what you are doing uh what you can
do is you can just sample a uniform
random input
um with value 1 on the function f
and now we can we can also say okay we
just uh study one minus f
and we will say the same thing for one
minus F you can also sample a pre-image
of one that is you set these variables
to be zero
so so all in all I'm saying that as a
player if you can sample in from random
pre-image of one then you can in fact
set this
restricted blocks
such that you get either zero one so
that's not a constant
and the probability to sample will help
us to
um
to analyze the variance of the
restricted function but that's not what
we need to worry
is this clear
yeah so this is how it's connected to
our theorem
the next uh uh I guess it's more
straightforward how this Control process
is related to the previous random
processes
that is we are going to ask the player
to implement the strategy that is to
just simulate
the condition process
so
so before uh so like so okay so whenever
um
the player get a chance
to play what he should do is try to uh
get set the probability distribution of
setting plus one minute minus one in a
way so that in the end this distribution
is the same as the distribution of the
condition process
and if you set this goal you can
actually
calculate what are these numbers
and uh
it's going to be like half plus minus
the partial derivative function
which is back to the variable to expose
at this
Point divided by 2 times Epsilon times
the value of function evaluated at this
point
and this Epsilon is used to compensate
for the fact that
you only have Epsilon probability to
play
anyway so this is just some
straightforward calculation
and the thing is
for this to be a valid probability
distribution it has to be the case that
the partial derivatives
is much smaller than like Epsilon times
the valuable function
so therefore our goal is actually to
study when this condition is going to be
violated
and for technical reason we are going to
uh uh just to consider two sub cases
maybe the first case is when the partial
derivative becomes too large any of the
partial derivative becomes too large or
the value of function becomes too small
so if if neither of these things happens
then your the valuable function will be
much larger than the partial derivative
and here like I said the Epsilon Delta
doesn't matter it's just some
placeholder
uh any question
is
inequality in the fact doesn't hold then
we
yeah okay so
the player strategy is to choose some
probability distribution so that the
player has a total effect can simulates
the conditional process
but uh for this strategy to be valid it
has to be
has to be this number is
a valid distribution
so if this thing becomes greater than
one then it doesn't make sense for a
probability distribution
in that case are we saying there is no
way the player or it's just this
specific strategy
fails but uh I'm going to say that what
I want to say is that
uh
this thing where all we were not built
uh because we said it's time to to be a
little bit ahead of the endpoint
okay
any other questions
okay so uh our goal is to analyze
uh when like our conditions does not
hold and in particular we consider two
cases the first case is when the partial
derivative becomes too large
and the second condition is when the
value of the function becomes too small
so as long as we can show that this
thing does not happen
very early then we are fine the player
can implement this strategy
and that is our goal
okay
so let's just look at these two
situations one by one the first one is
when the value of function become too
small
and this is actually easy to show
and just maybe just recall that
our condition process has this
preferences
towards one towards like larger sub
cubes
and in particular uh we call that I said
if you divide if you have this pass that
goes to some sub Cube that is very tiny
then our condition process follow that
passed divided by the uniform process
follow that path
is at most like the end point divided by
F0 and end point is very very tiny
so
this thing is upper bounded by a very
tiny quantity
so the probability that your condition
process go into a sub cube with very
small value is very very tiny so this is
the easy case
and the second case is we want to
understand
uh when our partial derivative become
too large
and recall that partial derivative is
related to the influence that's where uh
kind of we are going to use the max
influence is more
so
again we are going to use the fact that
our condition process in some sense is
not too far away from the uniform
process
so in particular I claim that we only
need to bound the probability that on
uniform
random process
what's the probability that
the partial derivative become too large
this is again just using the fact that
these two probability measure differs by
a factor of at most
F evaluated at your current Point
divided by F0
and that is at most wall
and the F0 is some constant so we can
ignore this part we just need to analyze
uh the probability that our uniform
process
will hit some point where this partial
derivative becomes too large in an early
point
so uh
here maybe I apologize that we need to
switch a little bit from a discrete
process to a continuous process
in the following sense
this is basically for technical reason
if you don't care you can just think and
as a discrete process
so in particular now we no longer have
this this create time zero one qn but we
have this continuous time the unit
interval
and then for each variable we are going
to just sample a Time point timestamp
from this unit interval
and what we do is we run our process
from time 0 to time one and when we hit
a Time
stamp for variable I then we expose this
variable
so now our goal is just to analyze the
first time that the power partial
derivative
of our function evaluated at points
sampling this way become too large
and we want to show that the stopping
time is at least to one minus episode
originally we want to show the time is
at least one minus Epsilon times n like
uh
in this zero one unit that's the right
scale
and simply like notice that a Time
T here
we kind of or we on expectation should
expose T times n
uh variables
okay
okay so next I'm going to show you the
analysis step by step
so
um
our goal is to analyze this partial
derivatives
of our function evaluated at points at
time t
so we just write it the this Max
quantity here on the
left hand side
and okay we say okay this thing becomes
too large
we are going to relax this maximum the
infinite Norm by a two plus ETA Norm
because we don't know which variable is
maximum
so we just sum over all the variables
and look at their partial derivative
Square Times
ETA you will see why we need this data
here is at least is very large
and next we are going just going to
apply the basically the markup
inequality for martingales
this is the next step
and finally not finally and the next
step we are going to apply a
hyperconductivity inequality
so we switch from this to pass air
handworm
to two Norm
except here
[Music]
what we are considering is random
restrictions
instead of the noise operator
so so we need to prove something
um
a little bit different although it's
kind of expected
that is we show that
if we have this kind of random
restriction and we fix some time Little
T and time capital T
then
the two plus
ETA Norm evaluated at this point at time
Little T is upper bounded by the two
Norm of our function evaluated at time
bigger t
so maybe let me uh expand it a little
bit so in a standard hyperconductivity
inequality
what we have is on the left hand side
you have your function applied with a
noisy operator
and then you can take a higher Norm
and compare with the tumor
and here what we are comparing is random
restrictions with time Little T Before
Time capital T
so at the at the beginning you have no
information about your input
and when you uh
run your process a little bit you expose
a little bit more information about the
inputs so you can think of this the
little T as a noisy version of the Dead
capital T
so this is something uh you can expect
to be true
and so we prove it
okay
so now so now we are at this step where
we use the hyperconductivity inequality
to switch from the two pass error Norm
to the two Norm
and now now we are sure like why we need
this data it's because
we are going to take this plastic had
two parts
um and bounded by the Mac the maximum
glance the individual influences
I mean recall that uh
the expected value of partial
derivatives the function at the end
point
is the influence
and anything and if you consider T to be
zero it's a constant function there is
no influence so this thing kind of
interprets between zero and the
influences
so we expect that uh
this value is less than
the individual influence this is this
this step or or maybe I should say this
is a submitting down
that's a more easier explanation
and then what's left is this
two more
but uh we can now apply uh
possibles inequality
in particular here we are just summing
uh all the variables and their partial
derivatives squared
but to recall that at time T
we already restricted at least on
average t fraction of your inputs
so there are like 1 minus t fraction of
inputs that is alive so for those moment
t-fraction of inputs you can apply
possible inequality
so the pressure the sum of uh partial
derivative squares is bounded about by
one
and that's kind of only counting one
minus t fraction of your inputs
so this is why uh you have this divided
by 4 minus t here
to get rid of this sum of
the partial derivative squared
okay
so at this point uh you're basically
down it's because we know the maximum
fluency is small
uh now all left is all I have to do is
just to
[Music]
um
optimize with your parameters
I guess uh maybe it's
it's better to stop
or I should
use the ads
okay maybe uh any questions at this
point
since being similar to
nice I guess this is something that
people
in fast drive you can think of like a
you're picking which variable to stay
alive
because if you if you if you if you
don't respect it then you play noise
is it
if I if I pick up a variable to keep
alarm for pgp
sorry to not keep alive before PVP okay
then then I pick a value at random then
it's like applying noise
I mean the the other way around but uh
when you have when you when you fix more
variable it's like revealing more
information about your inputs okay maybe
I got it wrong with that P yeah maybe
the direction is one but uh in any case
like restrictions and noise are where
you are seeing yeah yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
so so maybe expect that uh you can just
get this thing from the noise operator
from the standard app activities but
unfortunately we don't know how to do
that so we have to redo the proof
so like maybe the absolute values is a
little bit weird on the left hand side
that uh
I don't think that's it that's a rhythm
uh yeah but uh I don't know how to
explain uh
be derived
everything no no I don't think about the
absolute value is even without the
absolutely I don't think it's true well
it does not imply directly maybe smarter
way but we didn't see how it's implied
by the by the standard
s
since we have time maybe yeah
I just stay a little bit fewer about how
we bound the variance
so basically uh we so our idea is just
to compare the entropy like okay if we
are at uh
if we reach some random friction and
then
this is the entire building cube of the
intersection and this is what we kind of
get is a the subset which is a pre-image
of one for our function f
and we want to understand the size of
this uh small uh both
and we are going to basically analyze
the Chao Divergence
of our process
anyway if you don't care about
Divergence that's for this case it's
just the log the T minus the log of our
size of this ball so it tells you
um the number of
the fraction of ones in your input
so maybe uh
not I feel it's a bad idea
to say anything but anyway so so maybe
because our random process is to expose
the variable one by one so it's kind of
natural
um because uh it's kind of natural to
analyze the character Divergence because
of chain rule
yeah so we just write down the the
character Divergence but we just write
on the character evidence and the
conditioning of
um the random restrictions kind of and
then we
Maybe
[Music]
and uh
use some fact about like in the end if
we stop our our board has density less
and Delta and before the stopping time
the density is actually greater than
Delta
and we also use like the level one
inequality in some ways maybe I can talk
more offline
and uh somehow it's it's plays very
nicely altogether
so uh
maybe that's it thank you
[Applause]
any questions for pay so like about the
agriculture
sure
equals to one like the last thing
yes so so this capital t is actually
also going to be a parameter with your
shoulders
yes so
so this if I will depends on the bigger
team
and uh in reality I think we set this
bigger key to be a middle point that's
between this little T and one
this is not interesting it's just uh
trying to optimize your power
any more questions
I think you can deduce it from the high
performance activity field I'm using the
rich drawing
maybe true but I don't know
foreign
[Music]
activity for other nodes
so I didn't I didn't get it so that you
can look at the consider the distinction
thank you
thank you for a question
any other questions or comments
something
okay so let's think begin
and